the gyro can experience the idea in the
in Vedic thought is that there's davis
or higher beings and then there's the
devotee daiva the hot like a
judeo-christian tradition would say God
how much of what these people are
experiencing and talking about in the
bhagavad-gita and all the texts it has
to do with soma and has to do with
psychedelic rituals that they were
participating in while they were doing
these things so much do you know about
soma so funny you said that
yeah it's a commonly known thing I think
yea soma is a beverage on the moon okay
the moon is it's it's a beverage right
it's just that it's a combinatory
beverage a psychedelic sure Accra meant
that we don't we haven't established by
the way I'm speaking like a matter of
fact I understand I don't know I don't
know this
yeah well I'm saying it could be true
and this is what they like alright
that's how we learn the Vedas these are
the ingredients it's otherworldly you
can't try to recreate it on earth
there's plants they say that grow that
don't grow here and there's meetings
that grow now we just hear these stories
and we just it's myth but you know what
the zebras are myth I live a man I live
around a bunch of beautiful turkeys but
if you've you ever seen a peacock
turkeys look like boring you know what I
mean peacocks are unbelievable the other
thing Wow Quetzal is unbelievable you
know it's a loose sketch loses South
American bright colors what's his name
crazy Montezuma war hat so when you if
all you know is Robins an occasional
Cardinal when you see a cat solar
peacock it's like yeah right so someone
could say well you know you're really
gonna believe in the wind God come on
but we say hey look there's an ant on
the table and I blow on the ant pant
runs for his life in the ants brain he's
not thinking oh Raghu is blowing on me
he's just thinking Danger Danger Danger
yeah I'm actually be I'm a being I'm a
being with a family with ideas with
thoughts with a home
so the Yogi's say you don't know but
there's they say that everything is a
personality not just you because in one
sense if I look at you you're just a big
lump of earth and flesh you know water
blood whatever you whatever you want to
whatever lens you want to look at the
periodic table earthy of Chinese
elements in Indian elements however
they're going to look at matter but
you're not the Yogi's say you're not
that you just have that so they say the
earth itself is a being it's a living
being and all the animals are living
beings and outside of the earth there
are living forces that all the planets
are beings that's why there's here's get
ready for a detour that's why if you
study G ot or Vedic Astrology there's
different mantras to the different
planets because the planets affects your
karma so some people want to they
realize man like I would love to get
your chart done mmm because when you
have people like yourself or even myself
on a lesser level where we have some
some types of extremes in our life you
can read it in their chart it's it
becomes very obvious the same with
criminals it's in their chart really if
you really knew how little control we
have of our life it's shocking no this
strategy is is they call Jyothi Shore
Vedic Astrology
and it's based on a straw I'm no
astrologer I just have had my charts
done a lot it's an ancient system it's
not based on the sun's based on the moon
and what do they need to know they need
to know your your birth time your
longitude and latitude of where you're
born like for example I was born on I'll
tell you a good story
do you mind sure I went to a great
astrologer once and these guys are
really simple humble like humble people
and they lived in an ashram and I said I
want to know my chart and he just said
I'm not very good I said come on I've
heard you're the best he said I'm not
very good
and I said but I will tell you what
parish ARRA thinks of you
now parish sharra was the father of the
person they say scribed or spoke all the
Vedas vyasadeva was one of the great
sages of India
so par char was his father and he's
responsible for geo teach or the what's
called the horror Shastras where they
get the word horoscope from and these
are all to do with studying the luminary
studying celestial bodies and to
pinpoint you in relationship to them so
he said well at a certain period when
you were born there was a rising sign a
rising star and from that star we can
calculate your chart so he asked I gave
him all my statistics birth time and
date and longitude and latitude and then
he opened up these books that he had on
a shelf this guy doesn't know me from
Adam he just goes this is the star of
music and spirit and you will spread
music and spirit throughout the world
whoa it's pretty right on I've been
through some very powerful astrologers
palm readers mystics who don't even need
your palm they say they're astrologers
or they say they're palm readers they
look right in your face and tell you all
about your life and I kit and I'm not
one like I've met many who could blow
your minds I don't have to be someone
who doesn't doesn't know who I am yeah
well it's hard to find it's hard for you
but I'm less known but in India no one
knows - anyway but write it but but they
won't have to go to India yeah you know
it's one of those things and I'm not one
of these new-age guys right I'm a New
York skeptic okay but you believe in
Ganesh but no I believe Ganesh could be
could he be sure sure could be I think
most likely people were taking soma and
Ganesh appeared to them then or that
because I haven't seen things on
psychedelic experiences that are very
similar to that very similar to a God
I think psychedelic can bring you into
this yeah otherworldly realms and even
according to the
concept is there's other realms and
everything's divine and everything's
there everything's a person and there's
33 million gods and then of course out
and that's within the material universe
right and the material universe has
higher planets it has lower planets like
the Christians would say hell but
there's they talk about whole mandalas
or discs um layers of hells but they
with these differences from christianity
and i don't know where the christians
actually got a got it from or when it
was added or subtracted but the vedas
teach about none of them are eternal
meaning you don't stay there just like
we don't stay here we're just sort of
doing time on this planet we do time
we're learning a lesson you get some
karma you get some good good or bad
karma but we and if you don't learn your
lesson just like jail if you don't learn
your lesson sometimes you can add it and
add it sentence what if they all have
these yeah okay you two life sentences
you know right but sometimes people are
out early they get on they get paroled
they get pardoned or they get or that or
they just say okay you're in charge of
the library you're not dangerous you're
not a threat and we're gonna let you out
your good behavior so according to how
we behave in this world we're
perpetuating ourselves we're going way
low where we sort of go high and people
go high all the time it's impressive
and you take that micro and put it on a
macro as well and to the degree that you
sort of don't learn your lessons you
just that's okay I've noticed in my own
life if I don't learn a lesson I gotta
get that same lesson again
[Applause]